after writing the paper
comes the time of reading your paper a
few times in order to get everything
perfect
in this section you will learn how to
remove a lot of mistakes you might have
been writing
in the end you will have to build your
own checklist corresponding to your own
problems you want to avoid
after this your article can be submitted
and will hopefully be accepted
let's discuss the mistakes to avoid
before submitting the paper
let's look at content mistakes when you
are writing something you want to get
people interested by the content of your
article by the science behind it
but you also want to maintain an
internal coherent
so you have to make sure you answer the
following questions
do you pass the so what test does the
problem statement remain the same
throughout the paper
is the title of the paper coherent are
the keywords adequate
is the content of your research coherent
with the aims and scopes of the journal
you are targeting
the people that are going to read your
article are first the chief editor
then specialized editor then the
anonymous reviewers and finally your
community
be careful to be coherent and rigorous
so that they can follow your thinking
asking someone else to read your paper
once again is a good idea
he or she will give you his or her views
on how to improve the paper itself
and more importantly it can detect
mistakes
this person is going to give you the
first set of tips that one needs before
the submission
you can also check that your article is
not boring because then the peer review
process will just eliminate this paper
you have to keep in mind that your
writing is going to be evaluated by your
peers
improper language spelling mistakes
typos all these are a no-go
you should always be very mindful of
your writing because it can convey the
feeling that the paper
and the authors are not very rigorous
nor up to the journal standards
you will want to make sure that
everything is crystal clear that there
is no long sentence
that you are always writing in an active
voice for english papers
and not a passive one and there is no
need for complicated words
so just make it simple and straight to
the point
if you are like the rest of us you will
know it's hard to correct your own paper
so try and find proofreading buddies
some friends who will read your paper
and to whom you will return the favor
if english is not your native language
it is always a good idea to use a
professional copy editor
but do it when the final version of the
paper is available because this service
of language editing
is very costly if you have submission
deadlines
don't forget to take this time factor
into account
then there are some common format
oversights like forgetting the paper's
pagination
something which really frustrates
reviewers since it prevents them from
referring to a specific page in their
comments
also watch out for improper
bibliographical styles
always make sure you know the right
rules for the journal you are targeting
and always make sure you are respecting
their citing styles
for that you can often download a
template or the writing rules on the
website or the journal
it is important to follow the words
limit and all the guidelines that you
have to comply with regarding the
paragraphs
the font and the size and so on another
important point is the adequate
organization of the paper
make sure you have clear sections and
subsections as well as short
introduction paragraphs
or conclusion this helps clarify the
argumentation
and makes it easier for the reader to
follow also
verify that the titles of sections of
figures and tables
of the paper itself are the right ones
that they correspond exactly to what you
are showing in the paragraph
in the table in the figure and in the
paper itself
if you have specific form requirements
in your discipline make sure you comply
with them
in order to submit the paper you also
have to write a cover letter
which is a letter to the editor
describing what you did in maximum one
page
the objective is to convince of your
paper's interest
the same basic mistake can occur in this
letter so make sure you write a
well-crafted
interesting and clear letter in the
reviewing process we described before
you will then have to write letters to
the reviewers to answer the comments
always be respectful toward them and
mindful of their opinion
recommendation or critiques if they
don't understand what you wrote
it is probably because it was not clear
enough
but here again if you take care of all
the mistakes that we have defined
earlier it should be fine
in the earlier video on authorship we
have discussed icmje guidelines that
help researchers in deciding whether a
contributor qualifies to be an author or
not
in this video we are going to discuss
the order in which author names should
be included in a multi-author paper
the order of authors on a scientific
paper needs to be determined after
careful deliberation
prior to deciding the author order it is
important to understand the concept of a
first and a corresponding author
who should be the first author the first
author is usually the person who has
made the most significant intellectual
contribution to the work
in terms designing the study acquiring
and analyzing data from experiments and
writing the manuscript
the importance of the first author is
reflected in the common practice of
referring to a paper by the first
author's name publishing a paper as the
first author
is very crucial for the scientific
career of a phd student
after the first author the subsequent
authors are usually listed as per their
contribution to the research
starting with the one who contributed
the most to the least
however sometimes multiple authors may
have contributed equally
in which case the order of author names
does not matter
what is the role of a corresponding
author
at the time of submission of a
manuscript journals require you to
choose one of the authors as the
corresponding author
the corresponding author is the one who
receives all notifications from the
journal including manuscript status
reviewers comments and the final
decision
although journals usually perceive the
role of a corresponding author as purely
administrative
this role is associated with seniority
in some cultures
the corresponding author is often the
group leader or a senior researcher
whose contact
address is not likely to change in the
near future
in cases where the main contributor of
the study is also the group leader
he or she can be both the first and
corresponding author for the study
authorship for a student who has been
left off an author list
it can be especially maddening to see
someone included who obviously doesn't
deserve it
also called honorary or guest authors
gift authors don't make a significant
contribution
or sometimes any contribution at all to
the paper
motivations for gift authorship vary the
principal investigator
pi may think he's doing the recipient a
favor or she or he may think that adding
the name of a well-known scientist
will improve the odds of getting
published in a top journal
gift authors can appear anywhere on the
author list but usually they're listed
in the middle
gift authorship is especially damaging
when the recipient is a senior author
anyone who doesn't realize that the
authorship is honorary will wrongly
assume that this well-known scientist
has performed his or her role in
ensuring the integrity of the data
sometimes authorships are even gifted
without the recipient's knowledge
in summary as you can see choosing the
author order can be quite complicated
therefore we urge researchers to
consider these factors early in the
research process
and to confirm this order while editing
your manuscript before submission
to journals don't wait until the
manuscript is drafted before you decide
on the author order
all the parties involved will need to
agree on the author list before
submission
and no one will want to delay submission
because of a disagreement about who
should be included on the author list
and in what order additionally we
recommend periodically revisiting the
named author issue to make sure that
everyone is on the same page
and that the list is updated to
appropriately reflect changes in team
composition
or contributions to a work